this is Maddie Hassan so Hotes went on
many Hassan's show to explain why he
would not debate RFK Jr
yeah because I said I'm so fed up with
the debate me debate me because it's not
really about the debate if it was about
finding out information as you said
you've already written about vaccines
and autism you've already spoken and
written about covid vaccines I think
you've been on MSNBC and other channels
hundreds of times since the start of the
pandemic people can hear your views and
the evidence you bring to this so
they're not actually interested in
evidence and it sadden means that you're
a man who basically has saved lives
abroad with the vaccines you've
developed whereas RFK has contributed to
a culture of vaccine misinformation that
has led to the deaths as you say of
hundreds of thousands of lives and yet
he's the one being celebrated by Tech
billionaires like musk and Jack Dorsey
while you're being smeared and defamed
and I would say I don't know if you've
agreed to debate or not my advice is not
to people might find that surprising
because I wrote a book about debate but
I just think there's a time and a place
for a debate I don't think a historian
of World War II should debate a
holocaust denier I think just you know
that's that's my analogy here like I
don't think these debates between
experts and thanks to anything other
than Elevate the cranks
well you're absolutely right I mean
there are certain things you debate I
understand what a debate about 18th
century Enlightenment philosophy is and
and debating Rousseau and Bishop Bishop
Barkley I understand what political
debates are but in science we don't
typically do debates what we do is we
write scientific papers we present our
findings in front of a critical audience
of our peers to solicit their their
input and suggestions but it's you know
one doesn't typically debate science
maybe the one-off discussion of
Evolution versus creationism and that
sort of thing but that's not what we do
in science and so that's problem number
one and problem number two is to debate
with RFK Jr I've discussed this issue
with them many times by phone and by
email and the problem is you know he
just keeps on moving the goal posts I
mean first it was resolution
what's that
moving the goal post is literally what
conspiracy theorists do well yeah no I
mean and so then it was you know the
thimerosol preservative in vaccine then
spacing vaccines too close together and
then alumin vaccines then it was the HPV
vaccine that they said caused
infertility or autoimmunity and then
vaccines cause something called chronic
illness so you're always kind of playing
this pure game of whack-a-mole you knock
something down and it pops up or moving
the goal posts and and it's and it turns
out it's very unproductive and and it's
also pretty exhausting as well
exhausting unproductive it's
disingenuous as well and kind of
ludicrous I mean Robert Kennedy Jr is an
environmental lawyer I wouldn't expect
him to debate me on environmental law
and I don't see why anyone would think
that you would debate you know it's
really bizarre you can only talk to or
debate people who are experts in a
specific thing you can't have debates
with people who have fairly decent
knowledge to say the least about certain
things that maybe not may not be their
pure area of expertise also the way Mary
Hassan who is just such an awful
propagandist at a giant Network the way
he frames it that that RFK Jr is the
conspiracy theorist and the crank
well if that was true and now that this
thing had sort of become much bigger
because of all the money that was
offered to be thrown in because the way
the whole internet was looking at it
maybe hotels could be like you know what
though in this case this thing does feel
like it has like a seminal teaching
moment and I'll go in there and debunk
some of the things he said by the way I
did watch the entire segment which is
very painful to watch anything on MSNBC
like a full segment of it at no point
did they debunk anything that he said
like why wouldn't you just do what we do
on this show every day think how easy it
would be if the truth was on their side
think how easy it would be for hotels to
do this literally from home or Medi
Hassan with his team how they could just
take Clips like we take them take the
quote-unquote lies and conspiracy
theories and crank nonsense from RFK Jr
and then just show us the stats show us
the numbers tell us the truth
thank you